a week of protests violence and national
trauma started here in Zimbabwe
second-biggest city
collective fury in Bulawayo triggered by
the hike in the cost of fuel led to
widespread rioting and looting we awake
just kept in both indoors you cannot
move from one that one the house to
another place was we escaped shops and
businesses in large swaths of the city
were destroyed or stripped their
[Music]
business owners told Sky News they were
abandoned by the police and the military
for the first three or four days
officers doing little it seems in a city
dominated by the opposition MDC party
some 80% of the food outlets in the
working-class areas of blue air were
destroyed that's not just Luton the
capacity of these businesses to to open
again what was effectively ended because
their fridges were destroyed fridge
compressors were taken away angle
grinders were used to break down steel
doors and so they their businesses have
been trashed Zimbabwe is president
Emerson man and Jaguar has promised to
prosecute members of the army or the
police who were found guilty of
misconduct but they have little to fear
in Bulawayo instead it's members of the
public who are being rounded up and
arrested lawyers told us 500 people have
been detained in the past few days
we found no holomap oza outside court
carrying a toothbrush and some basic
supplies for her brother Josef it he ran
as a candidate in the last election but
was arrested on Sunday for organizing a
protest just waiting for
to tell us what's going to happen
because they don't have hope I thought
two data is going to be a trial day but
there's nothing they keep on postponed
on the day's the authorities have
reemerged in Bulawayo and Sky News has
heard and seen evidence of systematic
raids and punishment beatings in the
city's suburbs the police and the
military came to this neighborhood at 8
p.m. last night and they went
door-to-door administering beatings a
lot of people here who say they were
told to lie on the ground while they
were struck with batons people here are
traumatized I made those guys wake away
coming from I said I'm going home they
say it's after tuck lay down and then
nine guys eating me pie ten sticks and
everything come on Zimbabwe this is this
symbol I'm so I'm so so I don't know I'm
looking for a wait I'm asking what did I
do wrong
but they were continuously pitching me
and I don't know what to do now
because arms kid these are arbitrary and
unjustified attacks in a country trying
to sell itself as a democracy John
sparks Sky News in Bulawayo